puis décryptage et analyse on va plus
loin
[Musique]
et on va plus loin avec à mes côtés
Hamda mostafavid directrice adjointe de
la rédaction de L'Express l'hebdomadaire
qui vous allez le voir un face à une sur
Poutine le manipulateur des informations
chantages violence c'est à lire cette
semaine dans l'Express avec vous à
Mostafa vim bonjour bonjour et avec une
belle interview aussi de Andreï
l'écrivain ukrainien qui est interview
avec du Lano d'ampoli qui est l'auteur
du match du Kremlin donc je vous invite
combien de tours oui oui 12 13 fours
est formidable je vous conseille
également de le lire peut-être l'avait
voulu d'ailleurs également Gautier
ribinsky Chronica face à la France 24
bonjour bonjour
qui est un habitué à aussi de France 24
c'est vrai qu'on le recevait beaucoup
sur notamment toutes les questions
relatives à l'Italie pour la petite
histoire c'est une enquête elle qui a
démarré voilà quatre mois dans le plus
grand secret le révèle aujourd'hui au
grand jour les turpitudes et les
pressions qui s'exercent sur les élus
européens la vice-président grecque une
sur les 14 que compte l'Europe Parlement
Eva Kylie ainsi que trois autres
personnalités sont ainsi écrouées depuis
hier après la découverte de sacs de
billets un flagrant délit qui empêche la
députée de faire valoir son immunité
j'ai tout lumière crue sur les pratiques
jusque là condamnés par les parties les
plus extrêmes sans qu'on ose vraiment y
croire la corruption à l'oeuvre dans les
plus hautes instances européennes au
profit dans ce cas précis un état le
Qatar écoutait comment à réagi la
présidente du Parlement européen la
maltaise Roberta metzor
ma colère ma peine ne se manifeste pas
soyez assurés qu'elles sont bien
présentes ainsi que ma détermination
pour que cette assemblée se renforce
le Parlement européen est attaqué
européenne est sous le feu des attaques
et nos sociétés démocratiques ouvertes
et libres sont prises pour cible
hongrois Victor urban un euroceptique
devant l'Éternel est allé aussi de son
couplet il n'a pas tarder à réagir
partout il se moque des manquements du
Parlement à l'éthique salafuma le
comédienne
du Parlement européen en prison on n'est
pas on n'est pas sur voilà un second
couteau entre guillemets on est quand
même sur sur des représentants très
importants et évidemment maintenant tout
le monde se remet à scruter tout ce
qu'elle a dit ces dernières semaines
souvent des éloges du
Qatar ont tout est un peu rocambolaise
dans cette histoire quand même la valise
de billets on est dans on est dans une
affaire assez étonnante qui évidemment
en tâche le Parlement européen montre
que
les lobbies malheureusement on influence
encore trop forte vis-à-vis des euros
députés et montre aussi évidemment que
le Qatar du début jusqu'à la fin de
cette Coupe du Monde on aura eu des
scandales de ce genre et c'est quand
même voilà
ici du sportif on se régale histoire de
boycott on a remarqué que tout le monde
était à fond sur le foot et tout ça est
passé mais quand même il faut qu'à un
moment donné tirer les leçons de ce qui
s'est passé alors justement vous le
disiez on se reprend à scruter
finalement les déclarations de ces euros
députés parmi les personnalités visées
par cette enquête justement le redécuté
marc Taravella a vu son domicile
perquisitionner écouter ce que disait ce
socialiste belge voilà un mois seulement
interrogé sur les menaces de boycott de
la Coupe du Monde au Qatar face aux
conditions de travail sur les chantiers
de ce Mondial ce qui se manifeste
aujourd'hui et qui signent des
manifestes ce sont des carbiniers
d'Offenbach des droits de l'homme ça
fait des années que l'on a fustigé les
conditions de travail il y a eu des
progrès le Qatar le seul pays qui
abandonné la kafala dans sa loi c'est le
seul pays arabe qui l'a fait il y a un
salaire minimum qui est fixé donc tout
n'est pas parfait au Qatar évidemment et
loin de là mais aujourd'hui il faut sans
doute souligner comme le fait
l'Organisation internationale du Travail
la confédération internationale des
syndicats certaines ONG soulignent les
efforts qui ont été faits et leur
demande de continuer à l'avenir la
Gauthier étonnant parce qu'effectivement
on retrouve exactement les mêmes
éléments de langage chez
l'élu qui vient d'être incarcéré et qui
est inculpé aujourd'hui Eva Kylie oui ça
veut peut-être dire que si vous voulez
avec les billets il y a aussi quelques
fiches genre refuge d'un jeu quelconque
qui sont glissés avec des éléments de
langage plus sérieusement je voudrais
revenir 2 secondes sur ce que disait
Victor @ et que vous avez cité il y a
une énorme différence entre la
corruption en Hongrie et celle Parlement
européen c'est que c'est le Parlement
européen quel que soit les dommages et
les ravages qu'elle cause qu'elle puisse
causer elle est sortie cette affaire
elle est publique je voudrais qu'il en
soit autant à Budapest parenthèse fermée
qui doit-on blâmer dans cette affaire
est-ce que c'est le cathare dont on dit
effectivement que finalement il n'y a
rien qui soit plus étranger à sa culture
je parle bien la culture cathari pas
arabe que la propreté dans les dans les
et l'honnêteté dans les transactions
est-ce que il faut blâmer évidemment
celle qui acceptent la personne qui
accepte d'en croquer comme on dit
vulgairement mais au fond ce qu'il y a
de plus gênant je trouve c'est ce que
vous venez de diffuser c'est à dire
l'approbation quasi totale d'un régime
et de ces pratiques sociales et il a
vous avez quand même quelque chose qui
est qui est sidérant c'est que vous
savez c'est une question d'échelle quand
on parle de rien et qu'on fait un tout
petit progrès on dit mais c'est
merveilleux on a accompli un miracle
mais enfin attendez
cafala disparu ou pas ton il y a quand
même 4000 personnes qui sont mortes et
lorsqu'on dit c'est comme vous savez le
permis de conduire en Arabie Saoudite
pour les femmes tout le monde s'est
extasié en disant que MBS voilà un
souverain éclairé voilà quelqu'un qui
regarde dans le 21e siècle mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette affaire si
ce n'est heureusement la moindre le
moindre des petits gestes ou des droits
élémentaires pour une personne que de le
que d'accorder cette chose alors là
encore c'est un effet de de distorsion
ou de loupe on croit qu'à partir du
moment où le Qatar a fait un petit
progrès sur la chose il faut s'extasier
donc on a vu que le député belge a fait
ses propos et remarqué aussi la
vice-présidente grecque avait également
ses propos on croit où on fait mine d'y
croire parce que c'est vrai là encore on
entend beaucoup de de mots ressemblants
dans la bouche des uns et des autres ce
qui fait penser bien sûr des éléments de
langage un peu à l'image de ce qu'on
voyait pendant des années de la part de
laboratoire pharmaceutique et qu'on
voyait repris une extension dans
certaines propositions de loi qui
circulaient ou en tout cas de textes qui
circulaient au Parlement européen sous
la main des députés là il s'agissait de
lobby clairement identifié comme tel par
les règles européennes et bien oui sauf
que la défense d'un état ce n'est pas
considéré comme du lobbying est-ce qu'il
y a pas là un problème en Europe il y a
clairement il y a clairement un problème
qui va falloir parce que déjà c'est vrai
que pour les lobbys qui sont réglementés
reconnus c'est déjà assez compliqué de
de s'y retrouver et on sait qu'il y a
des dérives mais faut quand même saluer
en effet je suis d'accord avec Gauthier
la force de l'institution qui a un
moment donné mais
alors enfin voilà le Roberta midsola
elle est au courant elle est là quand il
y a des perquisitions l'hiver la
présidente elle a pas cherché à
minimiser elle elle fait quand on écoute
son discours c'est assez fort elle parle
la démocratie est attaquée voilà on a
l'impression qu'il y a eu un attaque
terroriste un peu voyez c'est de de cet
ordre là donc ça veut dire que quand
même il y a la capacité et moi je crois
dans la démocratie européenne dans la
capacité de l'Europe à un moment donné
justement à tirer les leçons de ça et à
peut-être assainir le le système le
Parlement européen devait justement se
prononcer sur un texte favorisant ou
donc à facilitant le régime des visas
pour les voyageurs du Qatar dans l'Union
européenne leur permettant notamment de
rester 90 jours au sein de l'Union il va
devenir impossible désormais de défendre
le Qatar sans être immédiatement
soupçonné de complaisance Gautier le
Qatar finalement va va perdre dans cette
affaire un certain nombre d'avocats à sa
cause
oui il y en avait de dire une faire une
mauvaise blague il y en avait-il
d'autres que ceux qui avaient croqué un
peu de la part que qu'un accordé le kata
bon il y en avait c'est au moins en tout
cas dans ceux qui l'ont de la rivalité
ou au plus fort de l'affrontement il y a
deux ans entre Arabie Saoudite et Qatar
avait pris le parti du Qatar par
opposition à l'arabe opposition à
l'Arabie Saoudite c'est vrai mais dans
quelle mesure le lobbying du Qatar
n'avait-il pas déjà produit son effet en
l'occurrence ce qui me gêne dans cette
affaire quand vous posiez la question de
savoir si il fallait museler en quelque
sorte le lobbying dans les instances
européennes il existera toujours ce
lobbying de la part d'État même interne
qui font partie de l'Europe la question
c'est toujours de savoir qu'est-ce qu'il
y a dans ce lobbying qu'est-ce qu'on
défend si on défend l'ordre appelons-le
comme ça l'ordre du Qatar l'ordre social
lors de patriarcale etc oui un vrai
problème par rapport à l'Union
européenne par rapport aux instants
c'est par rapport aux valeurs quand la
vice-présidente de l'union du Parlement
européen à défendu le Qatar c'était dans
des termes presque dithyrambique qui
aurait pu croire d'ailleurs que ça soit
véritablement son avis non c'était parce
qu'il y avait cette corruption donc le
problème avec la corruption ou plutôt
avec les lobbyings c'est de se dire que
ça existe mais qu'il faut toujours voir
ce qu'il y a derrière et ce qu'on défend
dans cette affaire là si un État
européen cherche à faire du lobbying
parce que par ailleurs il a des
inventions il a des idées il a des
projets qui peuvent être utiles et qui
peuvent être vertueux pour l'intérêt
commun après tout pourquoi pas mais là
qu'est-ce que c'est que de défendre le
Qatar aujourd'hui si ce nom si ce n'est
défendre des pratiques à la grand-papa
avec les valises pleines de billets et
surtout un ordre
institutionnelle on va dire morale
sociétale qui est inadmissible cette
affaire elle va porter un coup à la
diplomatie d'influence du Qatar d'après
vous je pense que oui après il va être
quand même difficile pour pour les pour
les personnes qui vous sera ramené à
défendre le Qatar sur la place publique
de le faire de le faire de manière
affichée après en coulisses il peut
toujours y avoir évidemment des gens qui
soutiennent le kata et qui font passer
on voit très bien voilà quand la
Commission européenne refuse de une loi
pour pour la toxicité des
achats toxiques dans l'agriculture on
voit pas forcément le porte-parole qui
s'exprime et qui dit ça mais à la fin le
résultat est le même donc voilà le
lobbying c'est quand même ça peut aussi
être subtil là ce qui est étonnant c'est
le côté voilà très rocambolesque et très
affiché mais le principe du loupéen
reste entier d'autant que le rôle du
Qatar reste en sous-main très active
dans un certain nombre de négociations
internationale on l'a vu ne serait-ce
que dans le cas de l'Afghanistan pour
maintenir un canal de négociation avec
des pouvoirs comme les talibans le Qatar
ne se coupent pas d'un certain nombre
d'acteurs jugé infréquenta pour nous et
c'est en cela qu'il est bien utile
Gauthier oui tout à fait il est bien
utile parce que précisément il a une
influence très souvent d'ailleurs par le
même moyen qui est celui de la finance
sur un certain nombre de parties en
conflit ou d'état en conflit et c'est
pour ça qu'on ne se coupe pas de lui
mais comment dirais-je vous posiez la
question madame tout à l'heure de savoir
à l'instant si la diplomatie du kata
allait s'en trouver enfin en pâtirer
est-ce que vous on ne risque pas
également d'avoir d'une part tous les
anti-européens style Orban mais pensons
à l'extrême droite européenne d'une
manière la nébuleuse c'est-à-dire vous
voyez bien on se fait avoir qui plus est
je n'hésite pas dire qu'il y aura un
ressentiment aussi raciste on se
laissait voir par des arabes on va avoir
droit à ça de la part de le le l'extrême
droite et puis d'autres qui diront mais
ils sont drôlement habiles le Qatar et
si nous qui sommes effectivement un peu
les dindons de la farce l'Europe parce
qu'il ne s'est pas se défendre donc ce
que je crois
probablement est-ce que je crois aussi
c'est que de la même manière vous avez
vu qu'au début de cette Coupe du Monde
on a parlé de ces problèmes vis-à-vis
des travailleurs qui avaient été sur les
chantiers on a parlé de des LGBT ça a
duré quoi quelques matchs et puis tout
ça c'était filochet et maintenant on dit
c'est drôlement bien organisé cette
Coupe du Monde au Qatar ben je crains
que cette affaire là malgré son côté
hautement scandaleux ne connaissent tout
de même sort en tout cas parmi les états
avec lesquels le Qatar avait décidé de
maintenir l'angle c'est d'ailleurs ce
que lui reprochait l'Arabie Saoudite il
y a bien sûr l'Iran l'Iran qui semble
déterminer à faire un nouvel exemple en
exécutant pour la deuxième fois
manifestant impliqué dans les
protestations Magic resa ranava qui a
été condamné pour le meurtre de demande
des forces de sécurité
écoutez-le tenter d'expliquer un son
geste devant ses juges c'était avant
donc le prononcer de la condamnation et
son exécution
ma haine contre les forces de sécurité
vient des clips publiés sur les réseaux
sociaux qui les montre en train de
battre et de tuer des gens
j'ai regardé ces clips et j'ai cru que
ce que je voyais était vrai
les 7 formes d'autocritique devant les
caméras AMDA Mostafa ville le signe que
le pouvoir iranien n'est pas décidé à
lâcher du lest non non c'est difficile
de voir ces images parce que c'est c'est
tellement évident voilà que il
y a des discours un peu prémâchés pour
essayer de dire voilà que c'est
l'influence occidentale que c'est les
réseaux sociaux que ce sont des fausses
images qui circulent c'est comme ça que
le régime essaye de vendre l'affaire
mais en effet ces signes bon voilà il y
a eu un moment où une sorte d'excitation
collective en disant ah c'est bon ils
ont un beau lit de la police des mœurs
tout est réglé bon on voit que non il y
a clairement il y a un durcissement mais
pourquoi il y a un durcissement parce
qu'en fait il n'y a pas d'autre solution
pour le régime islamique aujourd'hui de
toute façon ils ne peuvent pas abolir
vraiment la police démarre ils ne
peuvent pas revenir sur lui Jack parce
que c'est le voile islamique c'est cette
société
entre divisée en trois et femmes très
durement cette idéologie religieuse
c'est le fondement du régime donc en
fait si la jeunesse c'est terminé ils se
sont dit la seule solution c'est
d'effrayer c'est de durcir comme ils
l'ont déjà fait à plusieurs reprises en
2018 en 2019 et même depuis les années
80 c'est de durcir parce que le régime
se dit qu'il pourra survivre à cette
crise comme il l'a survécu à d'autres
s'il suffisamment de gens dans cette
jeune génération qui est une génération
nouvelle qui n'avait pas forcément connu
les autres répressions avance c'est
d'effrayer à nouveau cette génération
pour qu'il laisse tomber et oui une
renonce rien vraisemblablement le
pouvoir iranien puisqu'on l'apprend
aussi aujourd'hui la visite fin novembre
on ira que du Premier ministre qui a en
a profité pour renforcer son emprise sur
son voisin irakien Gautier oui même si
on a vu que les Irakiens par moments
manifeste des velléités pas
d'indépendance mais d'autonomie on l'a
vu quand un certain nombre de de
missiles c'était abattus dans le
Kurdistan irakien bon mais oui c'est
vrai qu'il y a une zone d'influence qui
est énorme avec toujours cette vieille
idée de du té islamique c'est à dire
d'établir ce qu'on appelle l'arc chiite
qui passerait de Téhéran par Bagdad par
Damas et ensuite par Beyrouth au-delà de
ça il y a évidemment la main mise sur
cette sur ce monde chiite mais surtout
le fait aussi que à travers cet arc s'il
était réalisé l'Iran deviendrait
indispensable et presque d'une certaine
manière inattaquable au niveau
international parce que c'est un peu
toute proportion gardée comme avec le
Qatar on aimerait pas se priver d'un
canal pareil pour pouvoir discuter avec
X belligérant et c'est la raison pour
laquelle on ne toucherait plus ou du
moins de manière très précautionneuse à
l'Iran et on va en reparler évidemment
très prochainement malheureusement j'ai
envie de dire parce que l'actualité
n'est pas très souriante du côté de
l'Iran ces jours-ci merci gauthierry
binsky merci Madame mustaphavi d'avoir
été avec nous on se retrouve nous
l'année prochaine AMDAM pour on va plus
loin et puis bien sûr demain pour une
nouvelle émission et dans moins de 3
minutes pour un nouveau journal rester
avec nous
[Musique]